[Music]
6 o'
6 o' on the nose. So, I would like to
call to order the May 5th, 2025
uh Langster City Council Finance
Committee. That's one. Uh the first uh
item we have is temporary resolution
46-25, a resolution to approve Lancaster
fiscal year 2025 community development
block grant annual action plan and
statement of objectives and to authorize
the mayor to submit the same to US
Department of Housing and Urban
Development coming from economic
development committee. Uh Councilman
Hope. Yes, thank you. So, um, this is
just an annual piece to approve the 2025
CDBG
um, funding and to get permission to
submit our annual action plan for these
funds to HUD. Um, it's an annual piece,
so it's pretty
straightforward. The total amount that
we're estimated to receive is
$488,22 and Chasyn is sick today. So, if
there's any questions, you're going to
answer them. I'll try. Chas left you all
alone. Yeah. No, we talked this morning.
So, okay, we're good. Questions of
councel.
Okay. You're waving your like you want
to talk. Doesn't look like it's anything
different than we've done in the past.
So, no. No. Um, so
correct. I know there was an email. Is
Mrs. Christ my second or is Cy? Corey.
Okay. So, Corey is my second. Three
readings.
Okay. Thank you very much. Next item is
temporary resolution
47-25, a resolution to increase receipts
and appropriate from the unencumbered
balance and amend the certificate of
other sources and appropriations with
the county auditor and the timbertop
tiff fund 3060 coming from the finance
committee. Um, and I'm going to let
Auditor Nettles explain this. Um this uh
first off, thank you for passing the um
last one that appropriate the carry for
cash. But as always saying, I'm day
late, dollar short. Uh after I did that,
that was passed. Then I got into a
conversation with um the attorneys that
handled the tiff for Gler and found out
that this is the second beginning of the
second year of this tiff that the tiff
was calculated incorrectly last year and
this year. I'm sorry.
um that was done incorrectly last year
and starting out this year. So, we had
to work on that and found it finding out
that now we're getting more revenue in
plus correcting last year's missed
revenue. Um which means there's more
money coming in from the TIFF. So, I
have to amend the revenue budget and
expense budget to allow that.
Any questions?
I understand you're requesting two
readings. I I'm respectfully asking for
two readings because um the developers
have their uh bond payment June 1st. So
if I put this money into um the trust
account so they can make the bond
payment um it would be in the red at the
end of the month if I didn't get this
taken care of. Okay. Thank you. And we
will have two readings unless of
objections.
And
uh we need to change. Councilman Sie
will be absent today. And uh who would
like to second that?
Finance committee. Council member Als.
That's right from But do we have to
change it all the way through or or can
we leave him as a second?
He'll be here next. Yeah. If he's not
here, then somebody else will have to
second all the legislation that he was
listening all the way through. That's
what I thought. Yeah. So, I need a
second.
Thank you, Councilman.
Unless Corey wants to do it. Cy.
[Music]
Thank you. All righty. Uh that's it for
the resolutions uh ordinances. We have
one temporary ordinance
25-25, an ordinance to authorize the
mayor to acquire the permanent and
temporary rightway necessary for the
East 6th Avenue Bridge over Federal's
Run Replacement Project. Uh that's
coming from public works and uh
Councilman Kener, please. I'm going have
Kurt come up and explain it and anybody
has any questions.
Good evening. Uh this is the Sixth
Avenue bridge replacement. Um it's this
is the third I guess time we've got
legislation on this. The first time was
to go after the grant. We got the grant.
Um the second time was to go forward
with the project um because we need
rightway.
Not a lot of right away, but we do need
room to replace that bridge, to replace
those
abutments. We're coming again to get
authorization to acquire that rideway.
Some of it's temporary easements just to
get in there and get the equipment. Uh,
a little bit of it is permanent right
away. I think probably from all four of
the properties there that abut that
bridge. Um, so we're asking for three
readings. Any questions?
Is this the uh bridge right opposite uh
uh Kroger's there? That bridge at that
corner between Cherry and No, it's a
little bit further west. Further west, I
think. Is it Medil there or Franklin?
One of those streets that commen. So
when's the what's the time frame for the
to occur? That's going to be replaced
next summer. next summer. Okay. I just
want to make sure it wasn't happening
when Main Street was having all its work
because that'll be two east west
thorough affairs tied up which would be
a mess. No, this is 26. Okay. 6th Avenue
will be closed. 27 will be doing the
sidewalks on East Main Street. 28 will
be paving East Main Street. So, we
Sounds good. We tried to get those to
match up. Sounds good. Thank you.
Kurt, this is the bridge they just they
had done a bunch of work to previously.
Yeah. When we were paving six, yeah, we
milled the asphalt off and didn't like
what we saw. The bridge deck was was
rotten.
Um, we were able to go out and raid it
and keep it open, but we didn't have the
funding at the time to replace the
bridge and it was too far gone to put
any money into it. So, we put the
asphalt back down. Now, we got to come
in, went out and got a municipal bridge
grant. I think it's an 8020. Don't quote
me on that. U, but got the grant to go
ahead and replace the bridge.
I thought that was that all we did was
replace the I mean that bridge was
closed for a while. Well, it was closed
the year before that for a combined
sewer overflow all summer. That's what
it was. Yeah. So, it was All right. And
then you discovered the the bigger
problem when you went and did the paving
project. When we're doing the paving
project.
That's why I thought you were talking
about the other bridge because we just
did all that work on that bridge.
Exactly. Yeah. No, I'm glad you brought
that up because we get that. Yeah. No,
we're not we're not replacing it again.
Scratch. Well, I wonder what do we do
the first time, right? So, thank you.
Okay. All right. Thank you. Dumb
question. Wait a minute. How much is the
bridge? How much is the replacement? I
don't think we ever talked about the
dollars. I don't know if I have that in
front of me. Thank you.
Um, yeah. Yeah, I'd hate to say 2
million. Okay, thank you.
Councilman Tiner had a question. I
wasn't talking to you. No, I just said I
thought they were done. So, okay, go
ahead. Luck. Um, Mr. Luck and then three
readings.
Okay, very good. Thank you. Uh, moving
on to departmental updates. Do we have
any this evening?
Yes. Thank you, Chairman Wolfinger. Uh,
I just wanted to let you know the
administration, we have been uh
currently meeting with and interviewing
um health insurance brokers. We've been
with our current broker since uh 2020.
And so, we thought that 5 years later,
it's probably a good time for us to just
shop around and make certain that we are
getting good rates and that we're
getting the most for what we're paying.
Um, so we have been meeting with three
different brokers and we're continuing
those meetings over the next few weeks.
Um, if we would decide to change
brokers, then we would be bringing forth
legislation to city council to enter
into a new agreement with a new broker
if if that would come up. So, I just
wanted to make you aware just in case.
Thank you. Any questions of that?
Okay. Thank you.
Further departmental
updates. Okay, I see none. Uh, tonight's
meeting President Porter. Excuse me.
Thank you, Chairman Wolfinger. Tonight
we have 11 resolutions on the regular
agenda, two ordinances. We also have two
public hearings, one on the NCA and one
on a blue label uh property resoning.
So,
thank you.
um items other items for finance
committee. Okay, I do have one item to
discuss
uh tonight. Temporary or temporary
resolution 3625
uh coming from the finance committee is
up for third reading. I initially made
the motion to introduce the legislation.
I will not be able to make a motion to
pass as I will be voting no. We will
need to make the motion to pass. Uh
someone else will need to do that and I
believe Corey has volunteered to make
the
motion. Uh my position
was is not was city council through the
finance committee passed permanent
resolution number
49-14 on March 10th, 2014. This
resolution transferred 100% of the
annual payment received from the prepaid
uh national uh gas purchase and sales
agreement uh and shall be given to the
city of Lancaster. 100% of that the port
authority to further economic
development efforts benefiting the city
of Lancaster. Um, this is an economic
development issue and I believe, correct
me,
uh, you might be the only one in the
room besides me that was around in 2014.
Is that you were on council? Oh, yes. I
don't beg if you were to. So, anyway,
um, that has to do with the prepaid.
There was a lot of money flowing back
and forth and at one point in time the
city had roughly $150,000 from the
prepaid money u to cover economic
development type of uh expenses um such
as the Lancaster SID and 33 Growth
Alliance and things of that nature. Um
at the time uh we were looking to uh
make the economic development department
full-time. It didn't happen till a few
years later and they needed to build a
budget. The vast majority of the money
was being distributed to the city of
Lancaster gas department and a little
bit of it as I mentioned referenced up
above. Um and when that was all passed,
signed, sealed and delivered, uh the
city received nothing on that. Uh I
personally feel that I since I was back
there then I understand the whole
process. uh this uh I'm not condemning
the survey at all. Um I would suggest
that's a good idea, but in all clear
conscious, I don't feel that I can make
a recommendation to motion and or to
vote for that. And I'd be happy to
answer any questions if anybody has any.
Good. Thank you, Mr. Wolfinger. I don't
have a question, but I have comment.
Okay.
So, uh, this is a housing study I think
we're in need of. We have questions
about single family homes, apartments,
etc. What kind of housing stock do we
need for this community to thrive going
forward? The ask here is five is
actually $5,000 even though the
legislation says $10,000. Uh, Stephanie
Bosow has been able to have other people
contribute to this overall. Um, and I
forget the total dollar amount.
Stephanie, 73,000. $73,000. So, the
city's ask is $5,000 at this
point. I cannot disagree with anything
Mr. Wolfinger said. I think it's an
accurate reflection of what happened in
the past, but I'm asking you to support
$5,000 for this study so we can have
this study and have something to operate
on going forward. So we as a group and
our community knows where we're at today
and where we might need to go in the
future.
Thank you. Thank you. Any other
questions, comments? Good. Moving on.
Um I see no need for executive session.
Um a motion to adjourn would be
appropriate. So moved.
Second. Counc. All those in favor
signify by saying I. I. It we are
adjourned and it is
6 6:15 6:15 very good it's a new
record uh the regular meeting of
Lancaster City Council will commence
promptly at 6:30 30.
[Music]
The Frankie Smith Funeral Home and
Crematory in Lancaster and the Johnson
Smith Funeral Home in Baltimore have a
long andul history of serving our
community. Feel free to give us a call
at
740-653652. Stop in and see us at either
of our two locations, 405 North Columbus
Street in Lancaster and 207 South Main
Street in Baltimore. Respect for
tradition, regard for change.
[Music]
Hi, I'm Travis Markwood from the Lanster
Fair County Chamber of Commerce. Our
focus is support, grow, build community,
and add value as we educate and advocate
local business organizations. This
month, we are really excited to be
chosen as the recipient of the Buckeye
Cares program. That means Buckeye will
make a generous donation to us with
every vehicle they sell this month. From
all of us at the Langster Fairfield
County Chamber of Commerce, we say thank
you, Buckeye.
[Music]
I call the May 5th, 2025 Lancaster City
Council meeting to order. Uh please rise
if you're able and join me in a moment
of prayer. God grant us the serenity to
accept the things that we cannot change,
the courage to change the things can't,
and finally the wisdom to know the
difference. Please join me in the pledge
of allegiance.
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
republic for which it stands, one nation
under God, indivisible, with liberty and
justice for all.
Will you please call Mr. Als here? Mr.
Bishack here. Mrs. Craigs here. Mrs.
Hoop here. Mr. Lockenberg here. Mr.
Spooner here. Miss Tiner here. Mr. Wing
here. And Mr. Wolfinger here. Let the
record reflect that nine members of
Lancaster City Council are here this
evening and present. Mr. President, I'd
like to make a motion to excuse Mr.
Sullie. Second. We have a motion and a
second to excuse council member Sullie
from tonight's meeting. All those in
favor, please signify by saying I. I. I.
All those opposed, same sign. We will
now move on to the reading and disposing
of the journal. Regular meeting minutes
dated April 21st, 2025.
Mr. President, I'd like to make a motion
to receive and file the journal. Second.
We have a motion and a second to receive
and file the journal. All those in
favor, please signify by saying I. I.
All those opposed, same sign. We'll now
move on to the reports of city
officials. Uh, email dated April 23rd,
2025 regarding 2024 state audit
submitted by auditor Patricia Nettles.
Email dated May 1st, 2025 regarding May
8th planning commission agenda.
Submitted by city planner, community
development director Chasyn Carter.
Email dated May 2nd, 2025. Inexation for
one parcel submitted by the law director
Stephanie Hall. Email dated May 2nd,
2025. Um cloud analytics report training
submitted by auditor Patricia Nettles.
And finally, email dated May 5th, 2025,
additional information on legislation
for timber top tiff uh submitted by our
auditor, Patricia Nettles.
Mr. President, I'd like to make a motion
to receive and file the reports of city
officials. Second. We have a motion and
a second to receive and file the reports
of city officials. All those in favor,
please signify by saying I. I. I. All
those opposed, same sign. Now move on to
communications. Email dated May 2nd,
2025 regarding annexation for one parcel
submitted by Christopher Tumblr, um,
vice president of residential
development. Maya uh mail dated May
5th regarding application to adjust
distribution rates with the public
utilities commission of Ohio submitted
by the Ohio Power Company AE.
Mr. President, I'd like to make a motion
to receive and file the communications.
Second. We have a motion and second to
receive and file the communications. All
those in favor, please signify by saying
I. I. All those opposed, same sign.
Special presentation and awards. We have
none this evening. Petitions and
memorials. There are no petitions or
memorials this evening. Thank you. We've
now reached the time in our agenda for
permission of voters and taxpayers to
address council. Do we have any
individuals present this evening that
would like to address
council? Seeing none, we thank you for
coming and attending this evening's
meeting. We now move on to the reports
of standing committees. I have four
finance committee meeting minutes dated
April 22nd, 2025 submitted by Mr.
Wolfinger. Economic development
committee meeting agenda um dated April
23rd, 2025 submitted by Mrs. Hoop.
Economic Divid development committee
meeting minutes dated May 2nd, 2025
submitted by Mrs. Hoop. Finance agenda
dated May 2nd, 2025, submitted by Mr.
Wolfinger.
Mr. President, I'd like to make a motion
to receive and file the reports of
standing committees. Second. We have a
motion and a second to receive and file
the reports of standing committees. All
those in favor, please signify by saying
I. I. All those opposed, same sign.
Reports of special committees. There are
no reports. We've reached the time in
our meeting agenda for public hearing.
We do have two public hearings this
evening. one on a new community
authority and another for blue label
packaging property. Um we will begin
with the uh public hearing on the new
community authority. procedures uh
associated with the um public hearing is
such that proponents must come up and
speak first. Have three minutes to state
their position in council and then any
opponents to the new community authority
may come forward and speak for three
minutes. Um there is a time for
rebuttal. Um, but you have to have
spoken during the first round in favor
of the um the new community authority.
So, I would begin uh by opening this
public hearing and asking, are there any
individuals here to speak in favor of
the new community
authority? Thank you, Law Director Hall.
Good evening. Um, just wanted to go over
the basics for everybody again. um just
in case there's any questions or
concerns. So, the new community
authority is a component of um the new
residential developments that we're
looking at doing here in Lancaster,
single family home development. Um and
it's kind of confusing because the new
community authority is based on a
property that the city owns inside the
city limits. That property is 12 acres
um out in the River Valley High. It's
actually designated for a park at this
time. It has not been developed as such
yet. Um, but the goal is to just name a
property that's in the city that the
city owns in order to allow us to use
this economic development tool. Um, and
the the benefit to the city is mainly
that the city can charge what's called a
community development charge. And that
community development charge will help
pay for the new infrastructure that
needs to be put in in order to bring
those residential homes to the city of
Lancaster. Um the new community
authority is actually going to be a
separate political subdivision. You as
city council are the organizational
board. Um and so you'll have a part in
appointing folks to the board just like
the mayor um will do as well. I believe
one of you actually um can be appointed
to sit on the board. Um but regardless,
it's a separate political subdivision
that will look out for the interests of
the developments that are coming. Um and
it's it's such that if at any point in
time, you know, the money has stopped
coming in um or the structure is not
working essentially, the new community
authority can go away. Um that's not an
issue. Once it's accomplished what it's
supposed to accomplish in terms of
funding, um it can go away. It can
continue. Uh it's kind of um up to the
the board of the of the um actual NCA at
that point. But again, you have some
control over that. Um, as does the
mayor. Um, and the goal is obviously,
you know, not to have the city have to
outlay all of the funds that we would
otherwise have to put out in terms of
ground and sidewalks and and um, you
know, fire hydrants and all that good
stuff that are pretty expensive. So, if
if I could ask a question. Sure. Um, the
12 acres is largely a placeholder
property. Is that correct? Just to get
to set up. Okay. You got it. Thank you.
Yep. Anybody
else? Great.
Thank you. Are there any further
individuals here to speak in favor of
the new community
authority? Seeing none, I would now ask,
are there any opponents here to speak
against the new community authority?
Seeing none, we will now close the
public hearing on the new community
authority. We'll now open the public
hearing on the blue label packaging.
Um, is it a resoning? It's a resoning,
correct? Establishing zoning. Okay.
Establishing zoning for the uh blue
label property. I would now ask if there
are any individuals here to speak in
favor of this uh
zoning. Law director
Hall. Thank you. Um so we put this uh we
put the piece that is supposed to
approve the establishment of zoning for
this um newly annexed property on the
table last week because we neglected to
to have a public hearing at city council
which we're required to do. Um, so
that's why it got pushed. But I just
wanted to make sure everybody
understands that this property um abuts
the property that Blue Label already
owns and is already established as being
zoned in an advanced manufacturing
district. Um, so this is just that that
triangle at the point between 22 and 37.
Um, that will be zoned advanced
manufacturing as well. That's the goal.
and we did a pre-annexation agreement um
if you all remember with the developer
um and we we advised that we would
support um their petition and their
request for that advanced manufacturing
zoning. So that's what I'm here to do.
If anybody has any questions, I'd be
happy to answer them. Thank you. Um in
relation to the legislation that is
currently on the table, would that come
off at the next meeting? No, it can come
off at this meeting. Yep. Since the
public hearing is being held now before
the legislation will be read. Okay.
Thank you. You're welcome.
Are there any further individuals here
in favor of the uh zoning uh adoption
for blue label
property? Hearing none, we will now move
on. Are there any opponents to um here
to speak in opposition to the blue label
uh
zoning? Uh seeing none, we will close
this public hearing.
[Music]
We will now move on to the reading of
resolutions beginning with the third
reading of temporary resolution 3325.
A resolution to amend permanent
resolution
70-22 authorizing the service safety
director to enter into an engineering
agreement for the various construction
administration and inspection services
during the northwater treatment plant
replacement project and to increase
estimated receipts appropriate from the
unencumbered balance and amend the
certificate of other sources and
appropriations with the county auditor
in the water utility reserve fund 6027.
Seven. This is through water and water
pollution committee. Mr. Wing and Mr.
Als. Council member Wing. Yes, Mr.
President. I'd like to make a motion
that council pass and gross and enter
upon the written record uh temporary
resolution number 33-25.
Second. We have a motion and second to
pass gross and enter upon the written
record. Temporary resolution
3325. Any discussion? Council member
Wing. Uh, yes, we've actually had a lot
of discussion on this piece, so I won't
belver all of it, but I just wanted to
thank the superintendents who made
themselves available to answer our
questions, and I can't wait for this
plant to be in operation later this
year. Thank you. Any further
discussion? Hearing none, please call
the role. Mr. Als, yes. Mr. Bisjack,
yes. Mrs. Kit, yes. Mrs. Hoop, yes. Mr.
Luenberg, yes. Mr. Skunover, yes. Miss
Tiner, yes. Mr. Wing, yes. And Mr.
Wolfinger, yes. Temporary resolution
33-25 passes 9 to0. Temporary resolution
34-25, a resolution to authorize the
service safety director to enter into an
agreement for engineering services on
the Frederick Street sewer separation
project. This is through water water
pollution um committee. This is through
Mrs. Mr. Wing and Miss Tener. Council
member Wing. Yes, Mr. President. I'd
like to make a motion that council pass
and gross and enter upon the written
record. Temporary resolution number
34-25. Second. We have a motion and
second to pass and gross and enter upon
the written record. Temporary resolution
3425. Discussion. Council member Wing.
Uh yes. This is another EPA mandated uh
sewer separation project. This one on
Frederick Street and not to exceed
$700,000.
Thank you. Any further discussion?
Hearing none, please call the role. Mr.
Als,
yes. Mrs. Kates, yes. Yes. Ms. Hoop.
Yes. Mr. Lockenberg. Yes. Mr. Skunover.
Yes. Miss Tinder. Yes. Mr. Wing. Yes.
And Mr. Wolfinger. Yes. Temporary
resolution 3425 passes 9 to zero.
Temporary resolution 3525. A resolution
authorizing the service safety director
to dispense with competitive bidding and
enter into contract with Rosenbar South
Dakota LLC for the purchase of a two
2026 Rosenbower Commander pumper truck
for the use by the Lancaster Fire
Department to appropriate funds and and
to declare an emergency. This is three
safety committee Mr. Bisjack and Mr.
Sully. Um who can who can be your
second? Mr. Mr. Wink. Mr. Wink. Mr.
Wink. Thank you. All right. Okay.
Council me Council Member Bisjack. Thank
you, Mr. President. I move that. Okay. I
move that council pass and gross and
enter upon the written record temporary
resolution 35-25.
Not back. Second.
We have a motion, a second to pass and
gross and enter upon the written record
temporary resolution
35-25. Discussion. Council member
Bisjack. Uh, thank you, Mr. President.
This will allocate one roughly $1.1
million coming from the uh safety impact
fee fund for the purchase of a new
Rosenbower pumper truck uh that the fire
department needs. Thank you. That's all.
Thank you, Mr. Ver. Appreciate that. Um
any other discussion
hearing none, please call the role. Mr.
Als, yes. Mr. Bisjack, yes. Mrs. Kes,
yes. Mrs. Who? Yes. Mr. Lenberg? Yes.
Mr. Skunover? Yes. Miss Teener? Yes. Mr.
Wing? Yes. And Mr. Wolfinger? Yes.
Temporary resolution
35-25 passes 9 to zero. Temporary
resolution 3625.
A resolution to appropriate from the
unencumbered balance. Amend the
certificate of appropriations with the
county auditor in the general fund 10001
to reimburse the Lis Port Authority for
paying its proportional share for the
Fairfield County Housing Study. And this
is through finance committee, Mr.
Skunover and Mr. Als. Council member
Skoover. Mr. Mr. President, I'd like to
make a motion that council pass and
gross and enter upon the written record
temporary resolution 3625.
Second. We have a motion second to pass
and gross and enter upon the written
record temporary resolution
3625. Any further discussion? Council
member Skuno. This is just us
authorizing to pay our portion of the
county or housing study for the for the
county. Thank you. Any further
discussion? Hearing none, please call
the role. Mr. ALS. Yes. Mr. Bisjack.
Yes. Mrs. K. Yes. Mrs. Hoop. Yes. Mr.
Luenberg. Yes. Mr. Skunberg. Yes. Mr.
Ms. Tener. Yes. Mr. Wing. Yes. And Mr.
Wolfinger? No.
Temporary resolution
3625. Passes 8 to1. We'll now move on to
the second reading of resolutions.
Beginning with temporary resolution
3825.
A resolution to authorize the service
safety director to enter into an
agreement for engineering services
associated with the flow monitoring
monitoring to be conducted with the
River Valley Highlands subdivision
sanitary sewer system. The water water
pollution committee, Mr. Wing and Miss
Ter. Council member Wing. Yes, Mr.
President. This will be the second of
three readings. Second of three readings
on temporary resolution
3825. Temporary resolution 3925. A
resolution to increase receipts,
appropriate funds from the wastewater
reserve fund two or 6029, amend the
certificate of other sources and
appropriations with the county auditor
and authorized payments of bills with
then and now certificates for the Ohio
water development loan for the solids
handling facility upgrade project. This
is through water water pollution
committee, Mr. Wing and Mr. Als.
Council member Wing, this is also the
second of three readings. Second of
three readings on temporary resolution
3925. Temporary resolution 40-25. A
resolution to increase receipts,
appropriate funds in the storm water
utility reserve
6019. Amend the certificate of other
sources and appropriations with the
county auditor and authorize payment of
bills within and now certificates for
the Ohio water development loan for the
east main street sewer separation
project. This again is through water
water com water water pollution
committee. Mr. Wing and Miss Tiner.
Council member Wing. Second of three
readings. Second of three readings on
temporary resolution
40-25. Temporary resolution 41-25.
A resolution to authorize the service
safety director to dispense with bidding
to due to a sole source provider for
membrane replacement for the upper
hawking water pollution control
facility. Again, this is through water
water pollution committee. Mr. Wing and
Mr. Adles. Council member Wing. This is
also the second of three readings.
Second of three readings on temporary
resolution
41-25. Temporary resolution 42-25.
A resolution to authorize the city of
Lancaster to apply for funding from the
Ohio Department of Development for CHIP
program funds. Um, this is through
economic development committee. Mrs.
Hoop and Mrs. Crates. Council member
Hoop. Yes. This is second of three
readings. Second of three readings on
temporary resolution
42-25. Temporary resolution 43-25.
A resolution to amend the certificate of
appropriations with the county auditor.
Appropriate from the unincomer balance
increase receipts completed fund
transfer in the CDBG loan repayment
revolving account fund 2075 in the
community development block grant fund
2073 and declare an emergency. This is
through economic development committee.
Mrs. Hoop and Mr. Wing. Council member
Hoop. And yes, this is first of three
readings.
Second. Second, I'm sorry. Second.
Second of three readings. Thank you. On
temporary resolution
4325. Temporary resolution 4525.
A resolution to appropriate from the
unencumbered balance in the general
fund.
increase receipts appropriate from the
unencumbered balance in the health
insurance management fund
7022 and amend the certificates for
appropriations with the county auditor.
This is through administrative services
committee Mr. Mr. Luenberg and Mr.
Bisjack. Council member Luckenberg.
Second of three readings. Second of
three readings on temporary resolution
4525. We now move on to the first
reading of resolutions beginning with
temporary resolution 4625. a resolution
to approve Lancaster's fiscal year 2025
community development block grant annual
action plan and statement of objectives
and to authorize the mayor to submit
this same to the US department of
housing and urban development. This is
through economic development committee
Mrs. Hoop and Mr. Skooner. Council
member Hoop, this is first of three
readings. First of three readings on
temporary resolution 4625. Temporary
resolution 4725.
A resolution to increase receipts
appropriate from the unencumber balance
and amend the certificate of other
sources and appropriations with the
county auditor in the timbertop fund.
Timber top tiff fund
3060. This is through finance committee.
Mr. Wolfinger, Mr. Als,
council member Wolfinger. And that'll be
your first of two readings. First of two
readings on temporary resolution
47-25. We'll now move on to the reading
of ordinances. Beginning with the third
reading of temporary ordinance 23-25,
an ordinance determining that the
establishment of the Lancaster New
Community Authority will be conducive to
the public safety, convenience, and
welfare. And it's intended to result in
the development of a new community and
declaring the new community authority to
be organized by a as a body politic and
corporate defending defining the
boundary of the new community district
and declaring emergency. This is through
economic development committee. Mrs.
Hoop and Mr. Wing. Council member Hoop.
Um yes, Mr. President. And I'd like to
make a motion that council pass and
engross and enter upon the written
record temporary ordinance 23-25.
Second. A motion in a second to pass and
gross and enter upon the written record
temporary ordinance
2325. Uh discussion. Council member
Hoop. Um no, this is just to officially
set up the NCA that Stephanie just spoke
about. Thank you. Is there any further
discussion on on temporary ordinance
2325? Hearing none, please call the
role. Mr. Als, yes. Mr. Bisjack, yes.
Mrs. Kitz, yes. Mrs. Hoop, yes. Mr.
Lockberg, yes. Mr. Scoover, yes. Miss
Tiner, yes. Mr. Wing, yes. And Mr.
Wolfinger, yes. Temporary ordinance 2325
passes 9 to zero. There are no second
readings of ordinances this evening, so
we move on to the first readings.
Temporary Ordinance 23-25,
an ordinance to authorize the mayor to
acquire the permanent and temporary
right ofway necessary for the East 6th
Avenue bridge over Feder's Run
replacement project. This is through
public works committee. Miss Tiner and
Mr. Luenberg. Council member Tiner.
First of three readings. First of three
readings on temporary ordinance 25-25
tabled legislation. Um we are we taking
that off the table this evening? Okay.
accept a motion.
Hold on. So, Mr. That's me, right? Um,
Mr. President, I'd like to make a motion
that council remove from the table
temporary ordinance 21-25
star. I don't think it's a star. Yeah, I
don't think it ever got amended to the
Oh, it didn't get amended. Okay. Because
it appears star on the agenda. Yeah,
there's some confusion because we
submitted a star piece and so that got
included on the agenda, but it never
actually got the amendment. Okay,
second. So, we have a motion in a second
to remove from the table temporary
ordinance
21-25. Um, this is non-debatable motion.
Please call the RO.
Mr. Als, yes. Mr. Bisjack, yes. Mrs.
Kes, yes. Mrs. Hoop, yes. Mr. Luenberg,
yes. Mr. Skunover, yes. Miss Teener.
Yes. Mr. Wing. Yes. And Mr. Wolfinger.
Yes. The motion to remove from the table
uh temporary ordinance 21-25 passes 9 to
zero. Council member Hoop. Um. Yes, Mr.
President. I'd like to make a motion to
replace temporary res ordinance
21-25 with
21-25 star as given to the clerk prior
to tonight's meeting. Second. We have a
motion and second to replace temporary
ordinance
21-25 with temporary ordinance 21-25
star as presented to the clerk in
writing before tonight's meeting. Um,
any discussion?
Not at this time. Hearing none, please
call the role. Mr. Als, yes. Mr.
Bisjack, yes. Mrs. K, yes. Mrs. Hoop,
yes. Mr. Luenberg, yes. Mr. Scoover,
yes. Miss Ter, yes. Mr. Wing, yes. And
Mr. Wolf, yes. Motion to amend temporary
ordinance 21-25
um and replace it with temporary
ordinance 21-25 star passes 9 to zero.
Council member Hoop. Um yes, Mr.
President. I'd like to make a motion
that council pass and gross and enter
upon the written record temporary
ordinance 21-25 star.
Second motion and second to pass and
gross and enter upon the written record
temporary ordinance 21-25 star. Any
further discussion? Not at this time.
Seeing none, please call the role. Mr.
Als, yes. Mr. Bisjack, yes. Mrs. Kes,
yes. Mrs. Hoop, yes. Mr. Luenberg, yes.
Mr. Skunberg, yes. Miss Tinder, yes. Mr.
Wing, yes. And Mr. Wolfinger, yes.
Temporary ordinance 21-25 star passes 9
to zero. That includes uh concludes the
reading of ordinances this evening. Um
we now move on to unfinished business.
Is there any unfinished business before
council this evening? Hearing none, we
will now move to new business. And
Council Member Kates. Yes. Um I just
wanted to make everyone aware that um
the upcoming law committee meeting on
May 23rd, um I did extend an invitation
to South Central Power um because they
will be on the legisl I'm sorry on the
agenda. And if anyone has questions,
please, you know, attend the meeting. Uh
that's at 9:00 at City Hall, 1897
conference room, which is on the second
floor. Thank you. Any further new
business before council this
evening, Auditor
Nettles, I know that there's been some
discussion about city debt and the total
amount that there is. um of that debt
that's listed in our our
financials, what is what is the
responsibility of the city and what is
what is known as conduit debt? Right.
So, we have that um the state auditor
requires um to be in our the city's
financials report, but is conduit debt
that the city has no way in any
obligation for and that's with the
Lancaster Port Authority, the prepaid
gas deal. There is approximately 300
million of that debt that does not
belong to the city at all. It city has
no um obligation for that whatsoever.
Okay? but I'm required to put it in my
financials. Um the state auditor
mandates it, but again, we're separate
entities with separate EIN numbers and
we're not liable for that debt. Thank
you. Um I just I just wanted that um out
because we've had some inquiries about
that and just having that bit of
information, you know, full transparency
is always helpful. So, we appreciate
that clarification. Thank you. Is there
any further new business tonight um
before city
council? Hearing none, we'll now move on
to the announcements of scheduled
meetings. Next regular sessions of
council is May 19th, 2025 at 6:30 p.m.
here in city council chambers. And then
again on June 9th, 2025 at 6:30 p.m. in
city council chambers. Special meeting
special scheduled meetings. We have no
special scheduled meetings. regularly
scheduled committee meetings.
I do have public works committee May 9th
at 7:30 a.m. at city hall 1897
conference room. Water Pollution Control
Service Meeting May 19th at 7:30 a.m.
City Hall 1897 room. Code Enforcement
and Zoning Committee May 22nd at 7:30
a.m. City Hall 1897 conference room. Law
committee um May 23rd at 7:30 a.m. City
Hall 1897 conference room.
I think that Oh, and safety committee
June 6 at 8 a.m. City Hall 1897
conference room and then I believe the
law committee um is actually at 9:00
a.m. this week. That's correct. Oh, 9:00
a.m. I'm sorry. No, no issue. I think it
used to be at 7:30.
Move on. Move on to the reading of
bills. I have one for
$144.81 for MNCO.
Mr. President, I'd like to make a motion
to pay the bill. Yeah. Second. We have a
motion, a second to pay the bill. All
those in favor, please signify by saying
I. All those opposed, same sign. Uh we
have no need for an executive session. I
will now entertain a motion to adjurnn.
Mr. President, I would like to make that
motion we adjourn. Second. A motion, a
second to adjurnn. All those in favor,
please signify by saying I. I. I. I.
It's 7 o'clock. Uh, this meeting of
Lancaster City Council is adjourned.
Please remember to sign your legislation
this evening before you leave. Thank
you.
[Music]